abone ol
Herkese merhabalar herkese ben Sercan
çatal bugün küllerinden doğmak teması
ile beraberiz hepimizin içinde bulunduğu
ve bizlere farklı yönlerden farklı
şekillerde etkileyen bir sürecin
içindeyiz kim lerimiz psikolojik savaşın
içinde bulur kendini kimilerimiz ise
fiziksel yorgunluk içindeydim
kimilerimiz bunu bir dönüşüm olarak
adlandırır sağda bir son olarak
nitelendiren kişi sayısı da bir hayli
fazla bu süreçte süper kahramanların
kırmızı pelerin takmadığını gerçek
kahramanların Aslında beyaz örneklerle
Hayat kurtardığını öğrendik her gün saat
7'de Fahrettin kocanın ekranı bekliyoruz
Aslında o mavi veri grafiğini tanıdık Ve
bir grafik görüntüsü hale geldik
kimilerimiz bu grafikteki sayılar olduk
Hatta kimi zaman bu sayıların bir insan
canı olduğunu unuttuk ve kuralları göz
ardı ederek hareket ettik bilinçsizce
tükettik ve bilinçsizce
bir aydır ve hareket ettik her durumda
gücünü arkasına alan cehalet toplumun
sahip olabileceği en vahşi düşmandır bu
sürece sayıları bize birçok şey ifade
etse de bazı sayılar var ki Dünyamız
değiştirmem uğruna gözlerimizi
kulaklarımızı kapatılmış sayılar Daha
doğrusu Canlar Bu sayılara dikkatiniz
vermeni istiyorum 285 milyon sadece içme
suyu erişemeyen insan sayısı 1750 milyon
18 yaşın altında Evlenen kız çocuğu
sayısı belli 7 milyon ilkokul eğitimine
dahi alamayan çocukların sayısı iki iki
küresel ısınmayı iki derecenin altını
sınırlayarak tehlikeli iklim değişikliği
önlemek için Paris Antlaşması küresel
bir çerçeve oluşturuyor şu
o günden güne değişiyor Günden güne
gelişiyor ve daha büyük sorunlar
küllerinden doğuyorsa bile temelde
problemlerimiz hep aynıydı eşitsizlikler
çok uzaklara bakmamıza gerek yok ki
yapmamız gereken çok basit bir şey vardı
aslında ortak noktalara Kıymet vermek ve
farklılıklara saygı duymak eşitlik
özgürlüğün ruhu dur Aslında onsuz
özgürlükte yoktur ancak öyle bir noktaya
geldik ki cinsiyet veren farklılığın
yarattığı işsizlikler Dünyamız bir kalsa
sürülüyor şu iklim değişikliği uzak bir
sorun değil Burada alıyor ve şimdi
oluyor bilinçsizce tükettiğimiz
Plastikler Sudaki yaşam da 100.000 canlı
türünün Yok olmasına sebep olurken besin
zincirinin En alt dalgasından en üst
halkasına kadar Herkes bundan
etkileniyor biliyoruz ki bilgi
çağındayız ve hızlı geçer
o yüzüne yarattığı rekabetten doğan bir
teknoloji eşitsizliği miz bulunmakta bir
Silsile Gecemiz gündüzümüz değişiyor bu
dönemde görüntülü konuşurken zaman zaman
ses veya görüntünün Senkron olmaması
bile psikolojimizin Fark ettirmeden
deliğin olarak etkilemekte işte bugün
belki de bu platformda bu dünyanın her
yerinden birçok ses mevcut eşitsizlik
düzenli Yurdu dedi adeta küllerinden
doğduğu ve birlikte hareket etmeye karar
verdim Kelebek Etkisi hepimiz biliriz
biz 16 yaşındaki genç bir kız dünyadaki
büyük liderleri konuştu Bunu duyan tüm
insanlık ise dünyanın her yerinden Bu
sese kulak verdim Toplum neden her
yaştaki yetişkinlerin eğitimi nden değil
de sadece çocukların Eğitimden sorumlu
kişi etmeliydi
bu bilgi her yerden erişim iyi aslında
da sadece anlamlı olması yeterli idim
küçük büyük demeden dünyanın her
yerinden değişim liderleri Bu sese kulak
vererek mevcut düzene dur diyerek adeta
küllerinden doğdu 2020'den itibaren on
yıl içerisinde size verdiğim sayılar
değiştirmek için tüm çözümleri tek
kavram tek Tama altında birleştirdiler
Aslında hepimiz şu an koruma çok
aşinayız yani gelecek nesillerin kendi
ihtiyaçlarını karşılama yeteneğinin ödün
vermeden günümüzün ihtiyaçları
karşılamaktır temel amacı Yani
sürdürülebilirlik bu yolda Hepimiz bir
bütün parçasıyız birimiz olmazsak bütün
olamayız başlamak için en iyi zaman şu
andır geri dönüp başlangıcımız
değiştiremeyiz ancak bulunduğumuz yerden
başlayıp hikayenin sonu hep birlikte
değiştirebileceğimiz inanıyor
bir ilerleme Sırrı başlamak başlamış
Sırrı Tabii ki de karmaşık gitti
görevlerinizi küçük yönetilebilir
görevlere vermek ve daha sonra emin
adımlarla başlamak ve burada Size bir
soru sormak istiyorum değişimi takip
eden mi alacaksınız yoksa değişimin
kendisine ve yine bu yolu sorulacak tek
bir soru vardır bir saç stilleri
kıyafetler takım formaları şarkılar
neden et değişir neden kusursuz bir
çözüm bulup on Sadık kalamayız yeniliğin
bir sorun yoktur Çünkü hiçbir zaman
doğru olan şey değil Bir sonraki şey
ilişkidir aslında yeni olan ve
değişmeyen tek şey de değişimin
kendisidir ve yeni olan şey de hızla
Bizim normal ümüz olmaya devam etmekte
de beyin önceden edilmiş bilgileri
kullanmak ile Yeni olasılıkları
keşfetmek arasında bir denge kurmaya
çalış
Biz bunu esneklik ve kat kat ılık
arasındaki dengeyi ulaşma halindedir
size bir kavramdan bahsetmek istiyorum
kamolrf yani takip etmesine iPad ilk
tanıtıldığı unda özelliklerin arasında
kitaplar dolu bir ahşap vardı programlar
parmağınızı ekrana kaldırdığınızda
sayfaların şehri mesinin eş değer bir
etki oluşturmak için epeyce hava çaba
sarmışlar çaba harcamışlar the Peki
neden Bunun yerine dişler çağırdın bir
kitap sıfırdan tasarlanmadı çünkü bir
saat renkli çıktı insanı Özden
birlikleri şeyler bir bağlantı olmasını
istiyorlardı Sonuç olarak tomofix
tasarımlar yeni normalleştiren
tasarımlardır gelişen teknoloji hızla
normali müze eğlenmeye başladım ve bu
noktada yaratıcılığın çok önemli
olduğunu söyleyebilirim kremanın
icadıyla Apple'ın iPhone'u
karşılaştırdığımızda ortaya çıkan en
önemli faktör yaratıcılık faktörü dümdüz
o insanlarla önceki deneyimlerine
birbirine bağlayan bilmiş ve yeni bir
şey senteze bilmişlerdir işte bu örnekte
de bunu göstermek istedim sürekli mavi
araba düşünürseniz Maviler ve görmeniz
kolaydır Sürekli yeni fırsatlar
düşünürseniz yine fırsatları bulmamız
kolaylaşır sürekli kızgınlığı
düşünürseniz kızmak için sebepler
kolaydır sürekli düşündüğünüz ş hale
geliyorsunuz O yüzden onu düşünün bu
örnekte anlatabilmek beş dakikanızı
alabilir ama bunun sancılı bir süreci
Elbette var Genç olmak hatalar yapmak
bunu özetleyen çok güzel bir söz var
aslında aptalca şeyler yapmasaydık bugün
akıllıca şeyler yapmazdık aksiliklerle
ilgili olan en güzel şey Biz
işlemlerinize tanıştır malıdır bir Ve
benim en sevdiğim anam bir kişinin bir
bilgi öğrendiğini anladığı an yüzündeki
o parlama anı
bu ve size depresyon hakkında bir şey
söylemek istiyorum Kendinizi çok mu
yetersiz hissediyorsunuz mutsuz
hissediyorsunuz bahanelerin arkasına
yatıyorsunuz Aslında Siz bu durumdan bir
örneklemeli Kurtarmak isterim sapını
kimine göre kara delikler Peki Kara
değildir yani sonsuz hapishanede değil
Kara deliklerin dışına çıkabilir veya
başka evrenlere geçiş yapabilirsiniz
birinin girişi bir diğerinin gelişini
hazırlar bir şeyin bitişi diğerinin
Başlangıcı bu yüzden ne gidişlerden
korku ne de bitişlerden her son yeni bir
başlangıç konuşmamın en başından bu
sürenin bitişine kadar bu sürecin bir
dönüşüm olduğunu düşünmemiz en
mantıklısı olur Hepimiz için ve sayılar
düşünelim sayıları değiştirmeye
çalışalım 1,1 cümlenin anlamını
değiştirebilir bir Suit bir gündem
bu ve bir insan bir fikir dünyayı
değiştirir her anımız güzel olmayabilir
ama her gün içinden mutlaka bir güzellik
vardır Tıpkı mavi araba örneğindeki gibi
ve size sonsuz dileklerimi sıralamak
istiyorum Bu hayat boyunca 5 adımda
daha sonra etrafta aramak yerine kendisi
doğru bir yolculuk yapın ve keyifli
çalışabilmek için sağlık zorluklara
savaşa bilmek için güç hataları kabul
etmek ve affedilmek için kapasitem
hedefe ulaşmak için sabır başkalarına
faydalı olabilmek için Sevgi hep sizinle
olsun beni dinlediğiniz için teşekkürler